I'm here with Vince Vaughn you might
have heard of him if you could give men
advice when it comes to picking up women
what advice would you give to men
we are here at model volleyball in South
Beach the hottest event on the planet
and we're finding out what women are
looking for in a man let's talk data
[Music]
Sonia we're finding out what beautiful
women are looking for in a man what are
the top three qualities you're looking
for in a man being reliable that they
trust me and good in bed don't slack
buddy funny hi and a good personality
loyalty ambition and caring intelligence
I also value a man who knows how to work
with like saving and money just so we
were clear I've saved a lot of money
find someone who has the same values as
you also finding somebody that is
willing to support you in everything
that you do and third thing someone that
you can have fun with dark hair fun
outgoing and uh Latin white blonde guys
need not apply nothing confidence
loyalty and I mean this is a little
shallow but I mean they gotta look good
too brains humor and a strong work ethic
you have to be Dependable reliable and
you have you have to be nice that's all
that's for is that too hard to freaking
ask gentlemen so if Amanda did have all
three of those qualities on average how
how long would it take for him to sleep
with you
sleep with me oh my god oh it's gonna
take a pretty long time to get in bed
with all of this I don't sleep with
anyone until I'm in committed
relationship that's like my thing oh
well I mean
Catholic Christian so until I was
married less than one
boom first day we're banging it depends
of the man on average how often ten ten
dates wow you got to work hard for Sonia
maybe two
how good looking he is maybe he want to
be super good looking yeah
and on the seventh day God rested he can
try three months worth of dates I don't
think it's like there's a certain number
like if I'm feeling it then I'm feeling
it if I'm not then I'm not you know kind
of depends I mean hey maybe it won't
even last more than two dates but I like
to get to know a person I like to kind
of build a friendship before I actually
run into a relationship like maybe a
month okay well worth it
no no no nothing's too soon
my thing is if I'm feeling the vibe and
the energy and I know that we're a match
I feel like let's see give us your best
advice when it comes to dating from Swae
Lee best advice make sure you come to
understanding
you know who you they know who you
dealing with you know what I'm saying
and if she got Instagram it ain't gonna
work and if you got Instagram it ain't
gonna work try to pick someone that you
kind of like and have fun with always
better if you enjoy the person and enjoy
being around them sometimes you could be
in a hurry to pick someone up but then
you kind of don't know if you even get
along so it's always nice if you have
things in common and enjoy each other
we're here asking women what they're
looking for in a man you're a pretty
attractive high value man what are you
looking for in a woman someone that
saves that money save that money let's
talk pickup lines if a guy wanted to get
your number what's the best approach
like if we're here hey girl I'll hold
this for you while you put my number in
no cheesy pickup lines do not come off
as a creep because like I can feel like
weird energy so like you know
I don't know I like cheesy pickup lines
I think they're funny unless you're like
weird then they're not funny then you're
just even more creepy you have to be
very respectful walk up and be like I
think you're so beautiful yada yada I
would like to get to know you have a
good conversation before and then just
ask for it you know just be up front not
like any kind of cheesy pickup line I'll
be like oh sorry I lost my phone do you
mind calling me so I could find it just
like say hey how you're doing hey how
you doing Victor I like Joey for friends
maybe casual conversation hit it off
first and then hit it with the phone
number like can I get your phone number
yeah but like talk first don't just come
up to me and be like hey you're pretty
can I have your number that does not
work no ever ever I guess just coming up
to me and like acting normal not so more
of like oh I can get you whatever you
want you know like kind of big Hot Shots
stuck up to someone like normal humble
genuine I usually give him my Instagram
so that I can like see who they are like
maybe see I don't know who they're about
hi um what brings you here what's your
name like what do you do like you can
start that way General background yeah
background questions no just like just
come up and talk to me not be like
cringy you know some of those like lines
are a little cringy and you're like oh
have you seen my friends
what does that mean I don't know I use
it all the time have you seen my friends
yeah and that's how you like start
talking to something even okay even when
I'm not looking for my friends amazing
what's the worst approach worst pickup
line a guy could use oh my God the the
Whistle the
I don't know why guys do that do you
believe in first I love at first sight
or you want me to come around again
that ain't gonna work for Sonia hey are
you single horrible it'd be a light
let's hang out you know I hate that
let's just hang out like what do you
mean hang out you know you want to take
Netflix and chill don't work for you it
doesn't can I take a quick survey like
put your number it was like some weird
cheesy [ __ ] if anybody approaches me and
says something that is physical about me
I don't like it hi you're pretty
no happened to me the other day I ran
away how you doing Ma like something
like that
Ma like ma sweetie it's just rude
hey baby girl how you doing you got a
man damn I just got really turned on
somehow the worst one I ever had is I
was actually at a baseball game with
four other baseball live and a guy a fan
came up to us and said so which one of
you wants to go on a date with me
tonight and I was like first of all rude
second of all if you want to go on a
date with anybody maybe next time don't
approach all of them like pick one okay
how often does a woman say she has a
boyfriend but she's lying
about
95 of the time because guys do not take
no lightly I mean I'm always honest I
don't know about everybody else but we
kind of live in Miami so honestly I
think it's 50 50. a lot of times girls
say that just so you shut the [ __ ] up 50
50 you know you never know right depends
on who's asking right yeah I mean that's
a good way to get out of a conversation
I have a boyfriend you know true so do
you have a boyfriend I do look 80 of the
time they're being truthful really 75
probably 60 of the time 65 percent she
threw a 65 not a 60. not 70 65. I don't
think it matters necessarily if a girl
saying she has a boyfriend she's
obviously not interested in you so you
should not harass her it's that simple
well who knows he depends because if she
doesn't like the guy she will definitely
use that as an excuse to get rid of so
how often is she lying all the time oh
they're lying all the time probably 40
of the time
I've said that and I'm completely
singles completely single but you're
lying to a man do you feel bad about
lying
no because if I'm uncomfortable and they
keep approaching me I'm gonna just be
like yo I'm just gonna call my boyfriend
normally I'll just be like hey I'm not
interested
what was that little dance movie
I don't know final thoughts on dating
relationships money go for it you got
nothing to lose by the way I can't find
my phone I think I lost it would you
mind calling me real quick
add value to people's lives I feel like
that makes you desirable what do you
think what have you learned from your
interview process that's a Thank You
Vince Vaughn for asking me a question I
think um yes for a guy I think it comes
down to head heart dick
okay you gotta have all three if a girl
only is getting one of the three it's
never gonna work if you find a girl that
can stimulate the brain is in your heart
but then obviously the sex is good what
the hell else is there what about the
ladies what are they you're gonna
appreciate this yes the number one
quality that a woman has said that she's
looking for what do you think it is
funny exactly yeah people like to laugh
and enjoy their time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]